hi I'm Gregory 9n and have you ever
taken a selfie
maybe time a kid a time or two well you
know sometimes I've taken innocent
selfie myself and there's a shadow up
there called top five
I'm nothing creepy backstories what's
with the politeness yeah we could talk
about it afterwards top five right now I
like you guys they like me I think many
cultures fear photography believing that
the mistress is art Native Americans at
one point believe that taking someone's
photograph could lead to an individual
soul being stolen and disrespecting the
spiritual world you might not know to
give this view a lot further thought
after learning about these selfies
creepy and disturbing backgrounds number
five ghost child captured in a 13 year
olds backseat a girl took a selfie in
the front seat of her mom's car and
capture dad oh sweet child sitting in
the back seat reaching out for her which
paranormal experts believe is warning
from beyond the grave 48 year old Louis
Katz was driving her daughter Harper to
a beauty pageant when the 13 year old
became bored and began taking shots of
herself the back seat was supposed to be
empty
however the mom of two claims she later
spotted the ghostly face of a young boy
lurking behind Harper ah camera when
taking pictures of something else
Melissa says there was a car accident on
the road they were driving along a
snowman oh my god and she did research
on the long stretch of road they were
traveling on she came to realize that
where the picture was taken there was an
automobile accident
someone had been medevacked away with a
helicopter which she claimed could have
involved boy however they would not
disclose specific details when she did
it in case which led to her further
believing of his child that may have
been involved as that may be the reason
why they couldn't provide her
Aries what are we shocked by the image
Louis is submitted it to Gregg pocha a
director of parapsychology after life in
paranormal studies at idolan project in
Canada
he claims that using an image analysis
also used by the FBI and CIA shows the
board's image in the picture has no
color temperature this he says adds to
the possibility that the photo may be
authentic as a ghost photo Gregg pointed
out that ghosts such as a boy are prunes
our main book so is literally written
over from the body in an accident
according to him chances are he does not
know that he's dead and chances are good
that he'll come back to haunt that area
of the highway forever God plot didn't
have her seatbelt on and hook up from
analyzing the photo thought that the
ghost may have been charged Warner
according to Melissa she has 13 traffic
tickets in two years due to Harper being
stubborn and not having a seatbelt on oh
it's another life dubbing this then this
woman could be actual proof of number
four Rafael goons are happening
Rafael Gonzalez his girlfriend Stephanie
Hernandez posted a shot on snapchat with
a boyfriend pointing a gun to her head
it looks like fun until a few hours
later the body of the 21 year old mother
of two was found by police with a single
gunshot wound to the head in a ransacked
home in Little Rock Arkansas 20 year old
Gonzalez was home with her girlfriend
when she first posted a photo of a gun
and ammunition snapchat it was then
followed by another photo of Gonzalez
pointing the gun to the side of her head
in what one would call a tracks twist
her girlfriends body was found lifeless
with a gunshot wound to the head
Gonzalez was taken into custody by the
police and given a 1 million dollar bail
after police executed a warrant of
arrest the couple was living with two
roommates who provided the police with
evidence as reported by the Arkansas
matters a male roommate who first
discovered Hernandez's body said
Gonzalez had admitted to accidentally
shooting her girlfriend before seeing
the home both roommates reported seeing
Gonzalez and Hernandez form around with
the gun
Gonzalez holy to her head why would you
the victims of high
800s stated in an interview that his
niece was getting her life together for
her two children having recently moved
to a new home with the roommates and
that she'd started any job truly painful
to suffer loss of life and was supposed
to be all jokes and games
Alan Alda has been linked to a number of
deaths over the past couple of years in
January 2015 a teenager from South
Carolina stabbed a classmate over a
snapchat and sent it to his girlfriend
ok number 3 for example selfie this is
one photo the Internet is losing its
mind over having sparked one heck of a
debate at first glance it appears to be
just a cute selfie of a couple a closer
look at the reflection on the back door
just proves otherwise
logically the reflection should have
done with after the woman's head only
it's the one staring at you the same way
you see her in the shop why I
wholeheartedly believe in the existence
of ghosts spirits demons in the light
then this picture would not be creepy at
all if not then whatever supernatural
phenomenon the culture first posted a
photo sharing website 9 what made its
way to Twitter sending chills to several
other social medias
the selfie snap in front of a window
where one can perfectly see their
reflection we don't expect the mirror to
reflect the back of her head I've seen
in the case there she is
smiling back looking all scream Wow
listen why her reflection is facing the
same direction is still unknown although
people around the internet are still
trying their best to provide an
explanation the most obvious explanation
in this picture would be Photoshop but
others strongly hold that there's
something paranormal bond is the man is
the Twitter account that posted a selfie
with the caption to question what kind
of a devilish thing is going on here it
received more than 16,000 retweets
reactions involves some people pointing
out that her hijab may have a different
pattern also hard to tell it might mean
that it isn't the same picture over on
9gag one user offer the most probable
explanation seeing that the picture is
the result of a camera with a real
shudder the sister is exposed to the
light with the help of two little panels
that fall off possibly down left or
right but usually on no use of further
states that if the girl was to turn her
head at the right moment the camera
would capture her looking backward and
forward the wider the gap between the
two falling panels determines the time
the sensor is exposed while the aspect
of Photoshop holds much more ground in
people's minds some still believe that
there is some Exorcist action going on
in the follow which if I believed it at
five years ghosts of the little girl
clutching anyway
Oh No why dimension
cinema the mother 3 then snap two quick
selfie of herself and her three children
like cinema and nearby you brighten the
room was indeed when the lights up and
credits rollin creating a perfect
scenario for the family selfie but when
the family checked the picture ones back
home Emma says she discovered a serious
critic figure in the background the
figure looked like a little girl with a
teddy next to her who her knowledge
definitely hadn't them in the room when
she took the photo was the first time
her son Harper had been to the cinema
she says she was really self-conscious
so she made sure that the cinema was
empty she even bumped into a friend who
had been on the back row and leader
shorter that there is no one there emma
added that her family is normally a bit
skeptical but everyone was a bit shocked
when I saw her the snap online
suggesting that the ghost could have
been a girl who drowned me at a coastal
cinema cast of course a number of people
accuse her of using digital software to
edit the photo what she insists she shot
the photo genuinely she didn't even know
where to start as she is rubbish with
technology
unknown woman's folded hands and a
selfie back River
Bethany harbor from Northern Ireland was
taking a selfie of herself and her
nephew when her sister photobombs June
she's in synthetic drugs Knapp chat
after story so everyone can see it but
as she claimed later her sister wasn't
the only one who photo
photo if you take a closer look at the
picture you could actually see a fourth
person in here that she claims there was
no one else in the living room oh oh I
didn't see that the ghost in the purple
dress in an interview with the Irish
mirror Bethany says she didn't notice
anything wrong with the snap until later
that evening when a friend of hers went
to the house and pointed out what looked
like a woman with her hands folded on
her knees in the background the face
cannot be drawn out in the photo but the
rest of the body can be clearly seen she
added a lot of creepy things have
happened in the house leaving her scoop
from this particular occurred Bethany
pointed out she does not feel more with
a room in the dark anymore yeah you're
she sees something yeah what are you
ghost or just Photoshop either way the
jumps were here picture duds in Cherokee
the body Oh way to go top five that was
a good 5 ok let's make that clear no Jay
no Jay did it oh man
all evidence points okay doing it ha you
like it there that bit in there man that
first story though got me a lot that I
just to be driving on a freeway and some
little beauty pageant of self-obsessed
doesn't buckle or a goddamn seat belt
teenager yeah that one's creepy like
just looking at it again right now yeah
with a little boy in the back nothing
clearly when you look you know closer
you can see lips and a chin like it's a
Kia form like it was just a head part
I'd be like oh that could be kind of
anything but on the bottom half of her
like hair there is clearly a face there
saying how she liked that I said the
mother did like crazy amounts of light
palm sound like she put everything on
hold for a while
and just the definition researching
contacted experts who this boy might be
we might not even realize he's dead
which is really creepy it's really
everyone involved kind of dumb boy also
I mean to me this doesn't really not
that I it has that much experience in
Photoshop but to me this doesn't look
like Photoshop because especially I mean
look at the lighting it's like very they
have the same kind of lighting on their
face
like it stops here kind of on his chin
it's like shadow again oh no I don't
want to believe things like this all
them were kind of fun in a scary way
except for the one with the
boyfriend-girlfriend
I was just that was just horrifying why
would you why would you play would
become like that and what like and it
wasn't it like one of their friends or
one of them that was like I'm just fun
yeah we're just joking around snapchat a
photo right before you accidentally
shoot her and why would you Stackhouse
sort of like all those bullets and that
gun like I'm not feel like at a shooting
range and yes oh I'm doing shooting
anything that I'm like okay well it's
not kidding or whatever yeah that gun is
a laser on it and everything
it just doesn't seem like like 21 year
old kidding dude good company man is so
young that you can't even joke like that
ya can't joke like that everyone knows
that everyone knows a li everyone but
then even if you're going to point the
gun like it into my way you're supposed
to at least put your finger around the
trigger like that not gripping it like
that as for safety all right yeah so you
don't accidentally pull the trigger
amateurs
amateur and he ran away there I don't
know how someone could live with
themselves if they accidentally kill the
person they love oh my god I can't
imagine I can't imagine killing the
person I hate yeah yeah yeah and then
all the ones the woman with the hijab
oh yeah then her face was face out okay
I think it's Photoshop it's creepy as
[ __ ] don't get me wrong
this is you're pretty creepy but I think
it's Photoshop there's no other
explanation for it and then that will
the I'm dead
anything no [ __ ] yeah I'm in Chris Wow
yeah no I'm not a duck yeah it's
definitely creepy and and part of it
they were saying like some sort of
camera shutter but that doesn't make any
sense
no I hate that because why is he still
like yeah I mean random his face well
you see the back of him up his head
right and this person looks a little the
reflection of the woman looks a little
different I think so too the nose looks
eyes look different to me my hands a
little bit it looks like a mustache on
the reflection versus like a smile uh
yeah alright this could be a shadow but
either way I'm like it doesn't it would
this kind of something I don't I don't
know what that would mean is the ghost
is there like a ghost haunting them it's
foreshadowing some outcome that's gonna
happen in them the same you think that
we could get away with some awesome like
[ __ ] so baby yeah absolutely
we should some be good for long ideas
Photoshop something so that people lose
their minds freak out 16,000 retweets on
here hello damn I could use rien wait I
get like four retweets if I tweet
something you know well we need to up
the ante up the ante throwing a ghost in
the middle of these reactions yeah
you're really just like right here yeah
yeah faces right here you just choose
your own adventure Oh
see mess on okay the fourth one was a
mother and the children that looks like
a face goes it does look like a fake up
it looks like something you'd see in a
movie yeah honey bear I just see a face
of the hood oh and they're saying like
no why why same teddy bear cuz I said in
the video I was like a young girl
holding a teddy bear
oh no I'll see young I just see a girl
peering over
lurking in the background legging but
she's she looks mad like why are you all
my theater yeah get out on that poor
family they're all gonna die we're all
gonna next yeah so what does it matter
there's a little bit earlier I mean
she's rubbish without a computer
knowledge yeah
but I feel like I feel like you can
download an app that can do that I feel
like it's gotta mean a breeze because it
really looks at like that song like that
like the one in the car the first one
yeah I'm like so much fun great little
bit yeah they look like a sixth sense
kind of ghost yeah like this looks like
my life introduce you I gotta go I don't
know what kind of ghost is real or not
because I've never seen a ghost
I've thought I've seen ghost but I'm
always wrong have you ever so what dear
what in your experience been lose
potentially see you do do you want to
share it here's a too scary to talk
about like I used to go to church my got
watery alright and I think about it I'm
gonna make me cry because because I
didn't see anything but I went to I used
to go to it's a good at our school when
I was really into Mel Gibson's Passion
of the Christ
yeah I saw it I was like you know I'm
gonna start going to church after school
I'm gonna be the only student going to
church after school so I go to church to
pray and I did this regularly for a
while and then one day and it's always
alone this job's always like people only
one integer really like what three ken
yeah like three three families earned
again that was the only one in the
church one day I'm walking up to go to
thee I forgot what it was called but
where you could kneel and pray and then
I heard a little girls voice go hello
and I looked around and I was I got so
smart
I remember that good I was scary though
like hello hello and no responded and I
thought in pray and I left hey did you
ever go back if it was like a mass with
like a bunch of people hungry but I
never went back alone after that day
as I was like two weeks straight and I
and I heard it was Sammy Clifford the
echo in my church echoed and and but
there was no one there
this is the little girls voice going
hello yeah I was pretty scary
that's scary so that's like your own
says that anything I want to just go
story and yeah I could have never had
what about you um just one I feel like
logically there's got to be a way I can
explain it but I don't know if there is
so I was home the childhood house that I
grew up in Michigan and so it has a
basement and then it has a first floor
and second floor so my bedroom was on
the second floor so I was home with one
of my sisters and we had a cat at the
time so my sister and the cat were in
the basement sure Jeff basement yeah and
I was on the second floor so like two
stories up yes okay
and I had my door closed you remember
like those those beads that you would
have like like back in the 93 like hang
up beads door yes I had those and and I
loved um I actually kind of miss him so
I was in my room door closed beads and
then like all of a sudden I hear like
this huge like like banging on my door
and I was like Theresa because that's my
sister's name who was home I was like
Theresa I was like silent and that I was
like this was creepy and I'll my name is
the cat that ran into this duel and so I
like open the door and the beads were
like swaying like this and and then I
was like
Tresa and she was still in the basement
she's like yeah I was like were you just
up here she's like no I was like where's
the cat she's like with me Oh like okay
and I don't mind a bit of weight like
maybe a window was open but like it was
like a slam though it was like a slam it
was so weird and there's I don't know I
have no idea what it I have no idea Oh
Jay did know Jenna's oj oj clearly oj
saw bronco leaving
my god I knew it
oh and then the girl yeah the Irish
woman laughs on it looks like Photoshop
because the pixels all look really
similar when it's up close it's just
damn good Photoshop would be but that'd
be a lot of night isn't it a lot it
would take a pro is it I mean we could
Photoshop anything into a background I
guess you can just take selfies and then
what don't like little ghosts stick like
a celebrity goes yeah what you're gonna
see how magically met a famous ghost
like a famous person who died and maybe
O's I want to be scary that'd be so cool
yeah I think that that would be the
coolest ghost that I like yeah would be
a famous one
or like a hot famous ones like a Marilyn
Monroe Oh that'd be cool happy so cool
that'd be cool
I would date a ghost choose Marilyn
Monroe I mean I think a lot of us would
knowing some of the people out there
that I date they have no emotion that
could practically be a ghost
segue subscribe to the real rejects
subscribe to top five unknowns
immediately the an woods Sun instagram
has a youtube channel
sort of sort of got getting there yet
well it'll mmm I'm sorry rolling and
yeah well the links in the description
box them is there anything else I don't
think so did you have anything else
thanks for watching
[Laughter]